- About to do this podcast,
so what's the name of the podcast?
- Analyze Asia.
- I'm ready.
(upbeat rock music)
I'm obsessed with the notion of all of us
who are listening right now
want to achieve something,
whether we wanna sell something,
whether we wanna run for government,
whether we want somebody to know about
our daughter's music skills.
And the way you do that is by
getting somebody's attention,
and then telling them something.
I am fascinated by
podcasts, by Facebook ads,
by KOLs, by all the different
things happening in the world
in all the regions, and
I think some things are
very overpriced, you know, direct mail,
billboards, television commercials,
and I think some things are under priced,
aforementioned KOLs.
So, that's what I do, and along the way
I've build my brand quite a bit.
I've written four New York
Times best selling books,
and I give keynote
speeches all of the world,
including one here today in Singapore.
- I thought it was very
interesting that you mentioned KOL
because key opinion leader,
that is a term that's used
in China, so you're understanding of China
is probably pretty interesting.
- Yeah, I mean, look, I,
you know, as you know,
and now to update all of you,
I've been very thoughtful
of entering the Asian market
mainly in China, we were talking earlier,
I, like many Americans, do think of it as
mainland China, then I put
Japan and Korea into a bucket,
and then I think about the rest,
but I'm very aware of Singapore
and Malaysia, Jakarta,
things like that.
I think about it thoughtfully,
You know, I pride myself
in being open minded and
thoughtful. I think American
business men and women
tend to be closed minded;
we're very insular.
It's something people don't
understand about Americans.
So, I've been very thoughtful
over the last four or five
years, paying close attention.
I was an angel investor in path,
so obviously I knew a lot
of what was going on here.
And, again, I think that there is
so much real, pure-bread
entrepreneurial spirit
in the overall Asian market
that I've been watching from afar.
Early this year, I took my
first trip to Hong Kong.
Now, I'm here in Singapore.
VaynerMedia has real ambition
to open an office here.
I have ambition to be in
mainland China twice next year.
Japan, Korea, Malaysia.
So, yes, I do have an understanding.
And there's obviously many things
that the mainland China companies
are further ahead than the U.S. markets,
and there's also uniqueness
in Southeast Asia,
platforms and execution that
I'm always paying attention to
because I try to figure out,
do they make sense in
an American environment?
How are our citizens different?
What are the infrastructure differences?
But yeah, I really wanna win,
and I think you can't
win in the next 40 years,
without being thoughtful
in every part of the world,
including Africa and South America,
and things of that nature.
- I've enjoy your books because
you always talk about social
media as a way to grab attention.
- Yes.
- And the way you think
about how to get customers
to come towards you, you're
very customer-centric.
- Yes.
- So, I only have two questions.
- Please.
- But I'm gonna move to that,
to the rest of the more interesting stuff.
Can you share about how you think of
social media that has evolved
from the past to today
and what are your favorite
social media tools?
- So, I think the only thing
that's evolved, and if you read
Crush It, which I wrote
in 2008, came out in 2009.
I'm as big of buyer on
this revolution as anybody,
and I'm glad I put it on paper, right?
So, I think the only
that's really changed is
nobody doubts it anymore.
This is change in
governments, and society,
and propaganda in a way that now it's,
I laugh when people,
I have business meetings where
people literally spend the
first 20 minutes talking
about Russia invading America
through it's Facebooks and this
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da,
and then all of a sudden,
we get to marketing
and they tell me Facebook's not that big,
they should still do television.
I'm like, wait a minute, what
about the first 20 minutes
when you said our entire
government is being
overthrown by social media?
But now to sell your blouses or your soda,
it's not important?
So, I think the only thing that's changed
is people's acceptance
of it and its scale.
My favorite right now
is definitely Instagram
because of its flexibility
and because of its
overwhelming attention and because
if you're trying to sell
something to somebody
20 to 45, it is the platform,
along with Facebook,
but a little bit more because under 27,
it's got so much more juice than Facebook.
And that is, you know,
obviously in all the markets
that Instagram is and some
of the people listening here,
it has not penetrated that
market, but that is my favorite
right now.
- I enjoy your books.
One of the things is,
the way you think about
business pragmatism, and of course,
the story of your family business,
so I wanted to talk about your two books,
Crush It and Ask Gary Vee,
and since you are here.
So in Ask Gary Vee, I know in
the first chapter, you talk
about the closet as a
metaphor, looking at high-level
principles, such as bring
value to the customer,
always play the long
game of lifetime value.
Can you talk about how do they guide you,
in terms of how you
think and how you execute
because you seem to be able to bridge it
pretty quickly and you feel that execution
is really the key to everything.
- So it's super interesting.
This is such a great way to start my trip.
I just want everybody to know,
I'm about to pay your host
here a huge compliment.
We don't know each other,
but I have a funny feeling we're gonna
know each other for a very long time.
I meet a lot of people.
I have the film, so if any of you guys,
maybe we'll send it to you,
and we'll use it for another podcast.
You said something now in your question,
I'm listening to the way
you're asking questions
and then obviously you have
the benefit of the last hour
and realizing how thoughtful you are,
something that I'm becoming
more in tune with is,
I'm the most consumer-centric thing
that I know of.
Other people, other businesses,
I'm watching how two of
my partners Acrim Ryson,
David D. Rock, just reacted,
I'm unbelievably consumer centric.
So, clouds and dirt, my thesis is,
if you care more about
the end consumer than
you care about your
own self, you will win.
So I talk a lot about 51-49,
for people that really follow my content.
I really live it, I
really genuinely live it.
I never make short-term
financial decisions.
I'm always trying to bring
more value to the other party.
I do that for a couple reasons.
Number one, I think I'm
talented enough to get
quite a bit in my 49.
I also think it's unbelievable leverage.
I also think it's a nice legacy,
I think it's nice to do, I think
it's a nice legacy to have,
and I do that with my
interpersonal relationships,
and I definitely do
that with my businesses.
So, my principles guide everything.
You're right execution's
everything and I think what's
interesting about the
clouds and dirt metaphor,
is it helps people paint a picture of
what I'm most worried
about; which is, I believe,
99% of the people listening to
this podcast spend an ungodly
amount of time in the middle.
I'll give you an example of something
in the middle, process.
Process is held on such a
pedestal in modern business
society and I find that be in the middle.
I understand its value, but I
do feel that if you push hard
on the clouds, your religion
and you push hard in the dirt,
the actual doing, that the
process gets commoditized
and you go faster.
And so yes I have principles
of bringing more value,
the lifetime value, attention,
arbitrage, as I mentioned
earlier and then I'm
never too fancy to do.
I mean, I will be honest with you,
I think even this 30 minutes
is a good example of that.
I didn't over ask Risa, I
have no clue how many people
listen to your podcast.
I'm never in a place where I
think I'm too fancy to do the
work and I take a lot of
pride that I'm a practitioner.
I understand Facebook and
Snapchat and Instagram,
these platforms better than
most because I use them
multiple times every day 365 days a year.
I think it's a huge competitive advantage,
and I think, obviously
you mentioned earlier,
HBS and Harvard, I think the thing
that I've learned as
not a good student and as an executor,
now that I'm 41 on the verge
of being 42 years old is,
man a lot of things breakdown
between theory and execution,
and I am absolutely
obsessed with execution
and I do think that theory
at a lot of times sits in the
middle, I think you have to
push yourself to the clouds.
To a bigger calling and I
think there's no better calling
than the end consumer,
if you're building a consumer product.
- There's a lot of startups
out there dreaming about
becoming unicorns and you have
been a investor of unicorns,
but I also understand you have
a very different perspective
to business, because I've
heard a couple of interviews
particularly the recent one on recoup.
So, can you share a little
bit about your philosophies
particularly in becoming sustainable,
focusing on top-line revenue
and optimizing for profit?
- Yeah I think it's a great
question and we got to speak
to it a little bit before as well.
I'm just trying make all of
you, who are listening jealous
that you missed out on so much
good stuff before we started
the podcast.
So, I'll try to fill you in.
Yeah I think again and I'm
gonna give you a compliment,
the fact that you use
consumer-centric and you used
practicality, I feel like a lot
of people are confused by me
I think I do a very good job
building a persona that makes
it a little bit of enigma.
The fact that you've been
able to synthesize me
makes me think you're
smart, which is interesting
and I guess this is what it comes down to.
My friends, we are living
through the greatest era of
financial arbitrage machines.
When I hear unicorn, yes
there's the companies that have
been successful, but to me I'm
worried, because I think most
of the people that are deemed
unicorns today are just
rhinoceroses wearing outfits
that look like a unicorn,
because a lot of the current
unicorns are not sustainable
with a macro economic slowdown.
And so, you brought up a great point,
which is, it may not be the
way we manipulate economies.
It maybe something like a war
or something else that creates
a need for liquid, that
will force a correction.
I think that's exactly astute
observation and to me the
question is very simple.
So for example, the business I run today,
it's 150 million a year revenue business.
It makes some level of profit.
This year the least that
it ever has, however;
if shit got difficult
next year, even during
The Great Depression,
brands advertised, right?
Not everybody goes out of business.
If shit hits the fan tomorrow
every brand in the world is
gonna start scrutinizing how it spends
its marketing dollars.
I believe if every brand lost
half of its marketing budget
next year, everyone, that my
company would grow 10X because
they would have to scrutinize
where they spend their money
and spending it with us is far
better than spending it with
WPP agencies that want to sell
highly profitable television
and programmatic banners.
So for me, I'm thinking about that.
I think a lot of the unicorns
are not profitable and they
need the next round of capital,
and if that goes away their
businesses break. And so I'm
yelling because it's too late
for Spotify or Ubers or
all these big companies.
They're on their way.
They're on their way but there's
a lot of young kids who are
in the middle, who are
raising their A or their B,
who have no thought, none,
of actually building a business.
What their trying to do is
build a big enough valuation,
so that on their third fundraising round,
they can take money off the table.
The fact that their kids who
are able to get to a C&D round
and are able to take tens
and hundreds of millions of
dollars off the table, without
ever building a successful
business is clearly attractive.
That's fine for a founder or
two, but when the shit hits the
fan, that's not gonna be good
for the investors and more
importantly, in my opinion, the employees
and I have a problem with that.
- Suppose today you can
tell your 20- year old self
something on business, what
would be the advice you give him
that you should not do?
- That's a good question.
I would say that your intuition is right.
That as long as you don't
die, this is a marathon
and it's a hell of a lot
better to train for a marathon,
than a sprint and that's it.
I can't, I'm so grateful
for where I'm sitting today.
Heading into the prime of my
business career with really
deep fundamental skill sets,
that will help me navigate
through no matter what
happens, going forward.
Both emotionally and in business and so,
I was a very unique kid.
I built a very build
big business in my 20s
and was still paying
myself $60,000 a year.
And didn't need stuff because
I wanted to be all-time great
and I kept reinvesting in
my businesses and instead of
buying watches and sneakers and cars,
and I wouldn't really want to
say too much because I would
be scared if I said something,
that kid would do something
differently than he did.
- Since we are in Asia, that
most businesses are actually
driven by family and one of the
things I actually identified
when I read Oscar reviews,
that you're also working in
family business too and I think
that's probably one of the
most interesting and very
under-talked in most of your
interviews. So, I want to ask you,
what is the experience like
and how do you navigate the
dynamics and working
with family?
- That's good.
- So, I've been getting into
with this a little bit more
now that AJ has left VaynerMedia.
This is probably the first time
I've really operated in some
pseudo-capacity of not
having family with me,
in my entire career.
Even though AJ's still on the
cap table and things of that
nature and I still talk to him about it.
Though to his credit, he never
asks and lets me do my thing.
It's probably the thing I'm most proud of.
I think when people look back at my career
and dig under the hood,
which even me saying that
speaks to the audacity that
I have and I want to be an
all-time entrepreneur.
I really do, but not because I say it,
because I execute.
I'm very proud that from 22 to
34, I built my dad's business
for him.
To give you the answer for
everybody who's listening,
because it's very hard, the
reason I've been able to make
family businesses work is
because I love my dad and brother
more than I like money.
It's just really not complicated.
Family businesses are difficult
because you're choosing
between family and money.
Let's make it very binary.
You can pull over on the
side of the road right now.
You can turn off your treadmill.
You can stop walking your dog.
I promise you that's all that's happening.
It's the love of your family
member, versus the money
and what's overlaid and
the hardest part is pride,
or the score, as I call it.
My biggest problem hasn't been the money,
it's been the competitive
nature of trying to figure out
who's better. Me and my
dad. Me and my brother.
The thing that has the most difficult,
is the narrative on
who's driving the ship.
Who's the best player on the
team and getting the respect
back and forth and I would
say, it was easier with my
brother than it was with my dad.
As that would make sense but,
I think the reason, I've been
able to be successful is a
little bit of 51-49, as I talked
about earlier, I do that
with my two family members.
But I would say this, it is
easily the most difficult thing
that I think most people have
to go through, because there's
first of all, it's hard
enough to build a business.
When you overlay the
emotional bag baggage of
family dynamics, insecurities,
fairness and I also
only worked with my brother,
who's 11 years younger,
if my sister had joined the business,
and she was 3 1/2 years younger than me.
If she joined the wine
business that would've
been another dynamic.
It is very difficult and
I would tell everybody the
following line:
you've got to try your best
to take a step back and think
about the funeral of
the other individuals,
and take that into account.
The thing that always
allowed me to navigate was,
I didn't want to be at my
dad's funeral and have regret
and I felt that it was better
to leave a lot of money
on the table and bet on
myself in the long term
that I would be able to close the gap,
than to have a no
relationship with my father.
And I think for a lot of Asian
youngsters, I feel like the Russian and
the Asian family dynamics
are far more similar than,
let's say a Russian or Asian
dynamic to an American family,
and so, I think a lot of you
are gonna understand that.
I, but I will say this as well,
I don't over react either.
I know your parents, like
mine, expected respect.
My dad wants respect
just because he's my dad.
I think that only goes so
far and so, if you want to do
something that is good for you legacy-wise
and you feel good about when
your parents are no longer in
the picture, I recommend that.
But I think you also have to
draw lines in the sand for your
own pride and your own life
and you have to be okay with
making tough decisions and
so I have a lot of empathy
on this subject matter.
- So, I want to come to VaynerMedia,
because
- Yes.
- you are coming to Asia with VaynerMedia,
- What inspired you to start
VaynerMedia and what is the
mission and vision of your company?
- I want to build the
greatest marketing machine
of all time.
I call it the DeathStar of marketing.
It's why I created a holding
company and why you'll hear me
start seeing VaynerX
more than VaynerMedia,
because of VaynerMedia is the agency part,
but I'm gonna be bubbling
out the publishing part with
VaynerX.
The visual is very simple.
I thought I was a unique,
once in a generation,
marketer, I know how ridiculous
of a statement that is,
but I needed to prove it to myself,
whether I was right or not.
And I thought the best way
to do that was to build an
infrastructure and a
company around my skill set,
and then what I wanted
to do was buy brands
and run it through them.
The Asian aspect of our
expansion and very much this trip
is a little bit about getting
acclimated to Singapore
with an ambition to open an office here,
is I just couldn't imagine.
Very tough to have a world
domination and not have a play in
Asia. So, as I see the next
30 or 40 years working out
in my career,
I was invigorated with
my trip to Hong Kong,
recently and I'm so
excited about this trip.
This is the beginning of a two-day trip.
There is just clearly a different
energy in entrepreneurship
and business that is a little
bit more in tune with me.
There's a reason why I think
I can only live in New York
and even that, and this is
a ridiculous thing to say,
and even at times New York
feels a little slow to me.
So, I'm looking for that energy.
That drug of high-intensity,
high-pressure,
winner attitude and I feel like
Asia, intuitively I felt it
and it's been confirmed and
I'm excited to see how I feel
in 48 hours but I'm excited about it.
- So, I know some of your
customers because I went to the
website. I know Budweiser,
Unilever, Toyota,
young Asia customers but in
specifically in US or Asia
globally, who are your customers?
Yeah, so we have Fortune 500 companies,
Johnson & Johnson,
global Fortune 500 companies
Johnson & Johnson's and Chase
and Budweiser, ABI and Unilever
and on and on and on
and so Turner Broadcasting,
a lot of the TV clients out
there in the US,
GE, these are major companies
with offices all around the
world and a lot of our expansion
is to do with a little bit
of the pressure I feel that we
have to become more global or
we'll become too one-dimensional.
For a lot of these companies,
as you can imagine,
America is a huge market but
every day becomes less of the
percentage of the overall business
and so we work with very big brands.
We've built a division
called the Vayner Beta,
we've built a division
called VaynerTalent.
So, we want to work
with smaller businesses,
because I don't want to lose those roots,
but when we come to Asia
it will be focus first
on the Fortune 1000
and then call it 2022, 2023,
I can start thinking about how
to service small and medium-size
businesses in the region.
- And the business problems
that your company is trying to
solve for the customers.
What are they?
- Every company in the world
is overspending on marketing.
Everyone of them.
- That's a good mission statement.
- And so, we would like,
I just want to historical,
I just want to be historically
correct that I'm right about
that statement.
I know I am and I think in
hindsight I'll win a lot of
points in history.
So, we are trying to get our
brands to reallocate their
dollars and every market is different
and so the way a Johnson
& Johnson or a Unilever
or a Budweiser or a Chase
or Toyota markets in America
is gonna be different than the
way they market in Malaysia,
or in South Korea and I want
to be great at telling them
what to do with their money
and then produce the pictures,
videos and words that help them achieve
their business goals.
- Cool. So you've just
launched a pair of sneakers
what's that that about?
- So, this is a super fun thing
for everybody who's in their
early 40s, like I am.
Specially if you had a luxury
of growing up in America,
sneaker culture is very big globally now.
But, I was a child of the 80s
when the Jordan's and Hewings
and the Barkleys and the Larry
Birds and Magic Johnsons,
when sport sneakers became a thing.
I was reached out to by K. Swiss,
about a year and a half ago,
and they said "Look, Adidas
has one by aligning itself with
Kanye, and they've won urban culture.
Obviously Nike and
Under Armor playing in sports culture.
We think of entrepreneurship
is a new pillar of fame,
and we think you're the face for it.
Would you consider doing a sneaker?"
Before he finished, Barney, the
president of K. Swiss before
he finished the statement, I said yes.
Because it was a win,
I only say yes fast when it's win-win.
The way I saw it is, I also
agree that entrepreneurship
is now on a cultural pedestal
and I don't think it's going
away anytime soon. So, I expect
other entrepreneurs to have
sneakers and for me, being the
first, is always interesting.
So, that was number one and
the number two, if it didn't
work, it would be a fun kind
of side-note for me and my
buddies to make fun of my
audacity, that I thought I was
cool enough to have a sneaker
and it flopped and I have 5000
pairs sitting in my garage.
- That's interesting.
So, you're in Asia now.
- Yes.
- I mean, I definitely get the
motivation why you came from
the US to Asia.
- Yes.
- Since you are in Singapore
and you've also been to
Hong Kong
- Yes.
What are your first
impressions of Asia with these
two cities?
- So, my biggest impression
and I've spent a lot of time
also watching from afar.
And when I say watching afar,
signing into wechats and
Q and all these things and so,
it's just just a
different level of rawness
that I appreciate.
And I don't, I hate when
Americans or Europeans speak to
"Oh the ethics are not as good."
It's all loser talk.
They're coming up with excuses,
I think there is a level of
ambition. A level of perseverance,
and a level of can-do attitude that is
intoxicating for real entrepreneurs
and so that is my first impression.
That people are people are hungry
and now look, I think China
is an incredibly intriguing cloud
and I don't use cloud as a bad thing.
But it is a thing, that I think the
Asian market always thinks
about what are they up to.
It's a thing and I
think that's intriguing.
So, I think it's a little early
for me to make a thoughtful
statement. I bought crypto
currency in 2013 and 14
and I'm still not on the
record on my thoughts on it.
So it's tough for me to think
about making my official Asian
POV but, the people have been so
disproportionately interesting to me.
It's the ambition, the ambition's real.
- Yep, I totally agree. So
it comes to the closing.
So I want to ask you two things.
One is, can you recommend
something that has profound
influence in your life in
the form of a book, podcast
or media?
- So, this is a tough question for me.
I'm a very unique guy.
The answer is sure but it's
gonna be a uniquely interesting
answer, which is my audience.
So for example, I just
connected from Hong Kong to
Singapore, four hour flight.
I slept, so even though it was
nighttime and I was trying to
get tired, what did I do?
The guy next to me is watching a movie.
Other people are doing all
sorts of different things on
their electronic devices.
I spent four straight hours
reading comments from people on
my content.
- Wow.
- So, I think the reason
that I'm a good culture
consumer-centric strategist
is because I probably spend
more time reading comments
than anybody I've ever heard of.
So when I used to talk
about in Thank You Economy
and gage, when I talk
about reply to everybody
and things of that nature,
what I didn't realize in 2011
that I now do 2017 was, I
was already reading everyone.
So, the addition of replying,
seemed like a very lightweight
task and that has been
unbelievably effective for me.
So, that has been my
greatest impact on me,
which has been the audience itself.
- So, I will definitely
check up all the comments and
(Gary laughs)
gift drop you a note.
- Please.
- So, my last question
is and I think this is
from me to you is a dumb question,
how can my audience find you?
They can find you almost
everywhere, right?
- Yes, I mean they can.
(interviewer laughs)
ironically one of our big
strategies is also to build out my
mainland China profiles
as well, but I would say
Facebook.com/Gary or the podcast is
being consumed unbelievably globally.
So, the Gary Vee Audio
Experience and a lot of iTunes or
Google play or Stitcher or
Spotify or things of that nature.
So, or you can Google
or search Gary V-E-E,
usually something will pop up.
(upbeat rock music)